hi guys my name is rudy and i play jj
one client and i play sarah cameron
hello i'm chase stokes and i play john b
what's up i'm jonathan davis and i play
pope hi i'm madison bailey and i play
kiara
and we're here with buzzfeed to take a
quiz to find out whether we're a pogue
or a cook
first how would your best friend
describe you funny
honest courageous passionate loyal or
spontaneous
how do you guys feel about me you guys
are you calling us your friends rudy
are you saying i mean i was gonna that's
a dude
i would say yes spontaneous i was gonna
say spontaneous what would you say for
chase
honest they're honest or passionate
i would say like funny or passionate
jonathan um
i would say i also think funny funny or
loyal
loyal yeah he's going to say lord you're
also super honest loyal
yeah again i think everybody here should
be
all all of these things i'm being honest
you all have all these qualities too
i love you guys you guys are great
madeline i don't know
i'm gonna actually say spontaneous i was
gonna say spontaneous
spontaneous you're a spontaneous
combustion person
hoagies pick a beach pick beach
beach looks like the barbados beach i
was about to say
those that yeah
it's probably sugar based right baby
barbados okay choose a sticker to add to
john b's van
for some reason i'm really digging the
globe i don't know why
i just like i don't know
is such a gas guzzler it is not
eco-friendly at all
so ironic to have the earth
yeah this is because we spend money on
gas doesn't mean that we don't
love the fumes coming out of them smells
like we don't like the planet
nobody passed out yet like being fully
honest the amount of
fumes that come out of that car right
this word's pretty cute too
like you showed the little turtle
the turtles the names croc i'm going no
way it's no fun
pick something to order at the rack
we got fish tacos always solid crab cake
salad burger and fries clam chowder
or sandwiched all of the above
i can't do any more seafood at the rack
after that
no after that first day yeah that's
fried chicken sandwich looks good
i'm going with the fried chicken
sandwich i also saw it they got it
they got a waffle and the pizza they
usually got a wobble as a bun
yeah i was like i gotta go fish tacos
i'm going fish tacos
i can't get enough of seafood we're
choosing a bandana
and we got six colors to choose from
here we got blue
red orange purple green and yellow
bailey takes red because she's raphael
and then chase takes blue because he's a
leonardo
uh i think you i i get it
i'm donatello i take it i love purple
and then i love purples i'm gonna take
yellow because i'm master splinter so
i'm taking yellow
you're right you sent your master
splinter i'm max winner
you're in the sewers of new york rudy
all right i'll pick another netflix
series guys we got stranger things never
have you ever retired king dead to me
sex education and ozark
tiger king sex education i'm gonna
for my homegirl she's a friend of mine
betrayal never have i ever their season
two is coming out too
dead that's my jam guys last question
and finally
which character would you trust was a
secret this is a big discussion
hold up no i'm actually with kline on
this one
i'm actually fine i'm gonna go wheezy
i i want to tell you something about why
that i never ever
anything ever i'm gonna go pope i was
gonna say pope
pope would already know your secret
before you told him i'd like yeah i
already knew that you didn't have to
tell me
facts changing is like 50 60. i don't
think jj trusts himself
so the pros and he might forget what he
told me
[Music]
you are definitely a pub you are opposed
i also got a pogue i also got
a boat like john b jj key and pope
someone you
who loves to live life to the fullest
mine says
i kid you not says a kook who wants to
poke okay
so what if cameron you may have been
born a kook but you fit in better with
the pose
you're energetic sincere courageous
you're someone who's always trying to do
the right thing and help others why you
love to get dressed up and
you're always sitting by the beach
thank enjoying things thank you guys so
[Music]
much